voters in San Francisco last night sent
a big message on Public Safety recalling
Progressive district attorney Chessa
Boudin after major public outcry that
his approach on crime was too lenient on
criminals now Boudin is blaming the
right for his loss
people are angry
they're frustrated
and I want to be very clear
about what happened tonight the
right-wing billionaires
outspent us three to one
they exploited an environment in which
people are appropriately upset
and they created an electoral Dynamic
where we were literally Shadow Boxing
sounds like a bunch of excuses to me the
results the people's voices were heard
and it sent a very clear message that
even the most left-leaning cities are
fed up with surging crime rates now Los
Angeles George gascon could suffer a
similar fate he's recently been under
Fire for issuing a very light sentence
over a teen driver's Hit and Run
Public Safety is everything I mean if
you if you talk to any family any mom or
dad or teacher anyone in any Community
regardless of the divisiveness and
politics race religion or anything else
everyone wants to know that they can you
know be safe that their children be safe
going to schools that they can walk down
the street in peace and and I think
that's really what this uh this D.A is
is just completely lost I served on the
Honolulu city council years ago my
district on the Honolulu city council
was a hundred thousand people
also the same size population as a mayor
Pete's city of South Bend Indiana but I
was chair of the committee that was
responsible for Public Safety uh police
fire lifeguards and understanding really
um this is not something theoretical
when you have homeless encampments as we
did on sidewalks you have uh elderly you
have disabled you have children being
pushed out into busy streets just to be
able to walk down the street those are
the kinds of things that we could take
action on and actually bring about a
change to clear those sidewalks and make
sure the community is safe there's so
many other examples and for this D.A to
be so out of touch is is just
mind-blowing to me and and Dane I'll
start with you you know his his response
from that clip blaming right-wing
billionaires and I think later he blamed
the police I gotta tell you if Jessica
Dean wants to feel better about himself
he should go and listen to this podcast
that NPR did this morning because the
reporter basically gave him every excuse
it was a pandemic also that he hadn't
changed any policy that the previous
person hadn't that there were um that
the people were really like that upset
about the quality of life that it's just
like really been exaggerated by everyone
I couldn't believe this piece and it's
again National Public Radio just like
listening to it this morning
um one of the Democrats that looks at
all these things from the Third Way that
group they said if the Democrats on the
far left do not see this as a wake-up
call they are looking at a permanent
minority status the other thing is is
that uh if you look at who voted for
Boudin it was very similar to who voted
for that woman who I can't remember her
name she was running against Eric Adams
the much more far left Progressive here
in New York City it was the Maya Wiley
thank you the ultra rich neighborhoods
the white liberal neighborhoods they're
the ones that voted for her and they're
the ones that voted for him if you look
at a map of who in San Francisco voted
to recall Boudin it's all the all the
all the rest of the people the rest of
the thing is blue and there's us that
one neighborhood that's so interesting
this is this is kind of your home
territory isn't it Greg yeah how do you
see like how did it get to this point
where go ahead there's a do you only
have so much shelf space I talked about
this so it's like I'm okay with like
tackling pronouns and talking about
statues and the the offensiveness of
holiday decorations but first get the
basic stuff down and what happened was
they replaced the basic concerns with
these external nonsense so what happened
was they also replaced the real victims
victims of rape assault murder family uh
family suffering whatever you any crime
was replaced with these you know
political identity victims of tick tock
politics you know the people that claim
that their feelings are that's what they
chased so I think that was that was
probably the big problem the other thing
I don't know if there's anything more
dangerous to a minority population than
a white leftist because they can they
can experiment with them they can try
out things and be immune from the
consequences so they can like they live
in the better neighborhood so they can
say hey let's release the criminals not
going to be my problem I'm not going to
be mugged and I feel so good I do I also
want to say you know what I like this
recall vote idea why don't they just
make it automatic every six months that
way you can keep because remember this
is a story of reality versus ideology in
reality one but look how long it took
three years since 2019. if you had it if
you had an automated recall vote every
six months they would have stopped this
thing well ahead in lives would have
been and saved yeah I mean I mean
speaking of of reality versus fantasy in
this age of you know words or violence
judge you've spent your entire career
fighting for victims of crimes to see a
district attorney whose sole
responsibility is public safety act in
the way that he has has got to just make
your blood boil it makes my blood boil
and all the DA's that I still keep in
touch with I mean the truth is the job
of a prosecutor an elected district
attorney is to enforce the law it is not
to worry about the defendant that's the
defense attorney's job and the judge's
job all right but what we're seeing now
I believe and I pray that we're seeing
the end of progressivism as it relates
to the left the left bought into this
after George Floyd they brought into
this theory that you know what the
criminal justice system is broken and
we're going to fix it we're going to
have equal justice we're going to have
equity and we're going to have Fair cash
bail and all that stuff but the truth is
the system wasn't broken because Derek
Chauvin who killed George Floyd was
convicted of murder he was convicted
he'll be in prison for the rest of his
life but now what they're seeing is that
what we've done is we've created a
scenario where the bad guys don't take
DA's seriously and they're continuing to
commit crimes and it's a problem for
everyone and I think it kind of reminds
me of the last segment with the White
House where the White House on the one
hand is encouraging peaceful protests
but they're not enforcing the law and
then what they're left with is an unsafe
environment in front of the Supreme
Court Justice's house and that's what
they're doing it's all talk and no
action and that that's where Jesse you
know I mean they're clearly out of touch
this is one of many examples I think
they can take a lesson from your book
and actually get out on the street and
go talk to people
[Music]
I ever have people over for a dinner
party and they want to change everything
about your menu they get in the kitchen
and they start adding things to the
dishes that you don't want to do like
you have a lasagna well why don't we fry
it no you bake a lasagna well let's put
some white wine no we're serving red
wine that's what liberals do they came
in after 25 years of low crime rates and
just wanted to experiment and just try
out this new stuff that was just not
commonsensical so they come in and they
say you know what
putting lots of people in prison it's
been working let's try something else
let's empty the prison and just not
prosecute everybody and then so all hell
breaks loose and this is what happens
when white guilt takes over you have
people that have white guilt and they
get in charge they get control of things
and then they try to assuage the white
guilt and they try to let everybody out
of prison and then look what happens it
ends up hurting more minorities than
anybody and as you said those people in
that little white guilt Paradise are
immune from everything else this is a
big warning shot first it was the school
board Knuckleheads then it was the
radical D.A the left is panicked over
what they're seeing in a hardcore
left-wing city of San Francisco count
out stupidity it's not just white guilt
it's a lot of stupidity it's both
no it's people buying into words without
looking at the actions that are taken in
addition to the words
I wanna Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now